i
[Música]
crisis política en honduras el país
tiene dos juntas directivas del congreso
diferentes luego de que los 18 diputados
expulsados por la presidenta electa
xiomara castró eligieran a su propio
líder del parlamento tenemos reportes
desde tegucigalpa
protestas contra la vacunación del
hobbit 19 y la mascarilla en washington
estas medidas siguen dividiendo a eeuu
muchos estados gobernados por
republicanos no imponen el uso de
tapabocas y otros gobiernos demócratas
si lo exigen para estar en interiores
y china aplica fuertes medidas para
combatir el coronavirus a menos de dos
semanas de que empiecen los juegos
olímpicos de invierno en beijing su
política de 'cero covite implica pruebas
masivas y separar a los deportistas del
público en general
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es maría
clara calle e iniciamos en honduras los
diputados que fueron expulsados por la
presidenta electa xiomara castró
instalaron hoy su propia junta directiva
y ratificaron a jorge cálix como líder
del congreso el viernes la mandataria
electa los aparto de su partido por no
respetar el pacto para escoger a su
nominado y mientras ellos hacían su
cesión en el norte de tegucigalpa de
manera paralela en la sede del
legislativo otro grupo de congresistas
escogió al candidato de castro para
presidir el congreso desde tegucigalpa
nuestra corresponsal kenia torres con
los detalles
honduras podría enfrentarse a una nueva
crisis política por el fraccionamiento
del parlamento por un lado se han
elegido dos juntas directivas paralelas
la integrada por los diputados
disidentes que obtuvo la mayoría de
votos gracias al apoyo de bancadas como
la del derrocado partido nacional y por
otro lado está la junta directiva que
acuerdo a la presidencia xiomara castró
y que nació a raíz de un acuerdo
establecido antes de las elecciones en
las que prometió la presidencia del
congreso a un representante del partido
salvador de honduras la misma presidenta
ha convocado a sus simpatizantes que se
encuentran aquí en los bajos del
congreso nacional en apoyo absoluto a su
decisión la mayor preocupación es que
castró gobierne con un parlamento
fraccionado y no pueda llevar a cabo
todas aquellas políticas de estado que
propuso durante su campaña según ella en
beneficio del pueblo
opositores venezolanos criticaron las
condiciones del consejo nacional
electoral para realizar el referendo
revocatorio contra el presidente nicolás
maduro el cn anunció que daría un plazo
de 12 horas para recolectar más de 4
millones de firmas contra el mandatario
los opositores creen que esto es una
bufonada césar pérez vivas promotor
nacional del movimiento por el
revocatorio nos explicó las dificultades
de los requisitos para el tema del
revocatorio la ciudadanía venezolana
está totalmente dispuesta y lista para
ir a firmar pero no me pueden venir
faltando 3 días a decir 1.200 centros
para recaudar cuando inversora en 44 mil
mesas de votación
eso es como meter 100 litros de agua en
una botella de un litro es absolutamente
imposible que los ciudadanos logren en
12 horas
ejercer su derecho en tan pocos centros
de modo que esto es una bufonada es una
falta de respeto a la inteligencia y al
derecho de los ciudadanos y es una nueva
demostración de porque nicolás maduro
tiene temor a que el pueblo venezolano
se exprese de modo que nosotros estamos
reclamando que se cumpla con las normas
que están vigentes tanto a nivel
constitucional como a nivel
administrativo para garantizar el
derecho a revocar miles de personas
marcharon en washington para oponerse a
las mascarillas y a las vacunas contra
el kobe 19 algunos de los carteles que
portaban decían que la coerción no es
elección es que la administración de joe
bailén intentó poner como obligatoria la
inoculación para los empleados de las
grandes empresas aunque la corte
suprema- bloqueó esa política el 13 de
enero escuchemos a uno de los
manifestantes
estamos en una guerra de información es
por eso que los necesitamos
tenemos que sacar esta información
crítica para salvar a la gente la gente
está muriendo nos están matando con la
censura y la propaganda están
manipulando las mentes de millones la
mayoría del sistema de salud a muchos de
mis compañeros médicos les han lavado el
cerebro por completo para que crean que
no existe un tratamiento nos dicen que
nos oponemos sin cesar y nos animemos a
nosotros mismos a pesar de que es la
única estrategia ha fallado está
fallando y seguirá fallando debe
detenerse
a menos de dos semanas de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno china está tomando
medidas drásticas contra los grupos
sospechosos de kobe 19 los funcionarios
de la capital beijing se apresuran a
realizar pruebas a los 2 millones de
habitantes de un barrio en el que se ha
detectado un pequeño número de casos
probando los límites de la tolerancia
cero los dos millones de residentes del
distrito frente de beijing deben
someterse a una prueba pcr tras
detectarse allí un pequeño grupo de
casos de kobe 19 mientras los países
occidentales registran cientos de miles
de nuevos contagios diarios en medio de
una oleada impulsada por la variante
omicron el gobierno chino se esfuerza
por mantener una estricta política de
'cero cobit hasta ahora parece estar
funcionando
la epidemia relacionada con la variante
omicron es en general estable ahora con
todos los nuevos casos procedentes de
personas bajo control de cuarentena la
epidemia relacionada con la variante
delta está actualmente en fase de
desarrollo con la cadena de transmisión
básicamente despejada este control sin
embargo ha tenido un coste tras un brote
en la ciudad norteña de chiang 13
millones de residentes fueron confinados
en sus casas durante semanas los
confinamientos también han provocado
duras restricciones en las ciudades de
tianjin y guandong
mientras tanto beijing se encuentra en
los últimos preparativos para acoger los
juegos olímpicos de invierno de 2022 en
lo que denomina un circuito cerrado que
separa todo el personal y los
participantes del público en general los
organizadores dicen que han detectado 72
casos importados de covite desde el 4 de
enero los expertos afirman que la
estrategia de 0 kobe de china podría ser
contraproducente ya que a diferencia de
los países occidentales la mayoría de su
población no está expuesta al virus lo
que la hace potencialmente más
vulnerable a los brotes cuando se
relajan las medidas
eeuu ordenó evacuar a las familias de
sus diplomáticos de la embajada en kiev
la capital ucraniana es la casa blanca
considera que rusia podría lanzar una
ofensiva militar en cualquier momento el
departamento de estado agregó que le
permitirá al personal de la embajada
salir del país si así lo quiere ya los
estadounidenses que viven en ucrania les
recomiendo que deberían considerar
abandonar el país de inmediato por otra
parte la casa blanca les aconsejó a sus
ciudadanos hasta rusia esto dijo el
departamento de estado
rusia el departamento continúa
recomendando a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses que no viajen a rusia
debido a la atención constante a lo
largo de la frontera con ucrania existe
la posibilidad de acoso contra los
ciudadanos estadounidenses y la embajada
tiene una capacidad limitada para ayudar
a los ciudadanos estadounidenses en
rusia y el lunes- guinea buscará a su
clasificación a los cuartos de final de
la copa africana de naciones
frente a la sorprendente cambia el
seleccionado tiene a varios jugadores
importantes como navy keita y cuenta con
una preparación física de primer nivel
france24 accedió a una sesión de
fisioterapia del elenco guineano
el día de partido para guinea
a pocas horas del pitazo inicial los
jugadores pasan sus controles de última
hora un ritual bien aceitado preparado y
sincronizado a la perfección bruno la
cruz es el fisioterapeuta del combinado
guineano junto a su staff llevan varias
horas trabajando línea ha invertido
mucho en su departamento médico 160 mil
euros en equipos de última generación
para luminoterapia crioterapia
ultrasonidos y resonancias magnéticas
combinados con técnicas tradicionales de
masaje un lujo que algunos de los
mejores equipos de europa no pueden
permitirse
a veces incluso los clubes de la liga de
francia no tienen este equipo es
material de última generación que se
adapta a cualquier tipo de lesión
deportiva
en este rubro guinea está a la par de
algunos de los clubes más importantes
del mundo lo comprueban abi keita
centrocampista del liverpool y capitán
del sil y nacional
esto realmente nos ayudó muchos
jugadores dijeron que esta vez las
condiciones son mejores ha aumentado el
número de oficios disponibles vienen a
nuestras habitaciones y nos preguntan si
necesitamos algo es importante para
nosotros que sean poco el tiempo que se
pasa en la sala de fisioterapia también
es una oportunidad para relajarse
aumentar el espíritu de equipo y aliviar
la presión de una competición
internacional de primer nivel pero es
además una necesidad profesional de los
jugadores en mi situación en este
momento realmente necesito este
tratamiento es muy importante para mí
recuperarme rápido vienen partidos muy
importantes codo a codo jugadores y
personal trabajan en conjunto para
garantizar que cuerpo y mente estén
listos para el encuentro un enfoque que
hasta ahora ha funcionado línea solo
tiene un jugador lesionado antes de su
cruce de octavos de final contra gambia
así llegamos al final de las noticias
ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]